翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Keisuke Yamashita
「Silt」とは 砂よりも更に小さく
砕かれた状態の物質を指し示すことばです
自然界において 私たち人間一人ひとりは
とても小さな存在です
その意味を込めて このことばを
我々のチーム名としました
しかし 人間はそのつながりによって
コミュニティを形成することで
大きな存在にもなり得ます
サンドアートもまた 一粒一粒の
小さな砂つぶが集まることで
一つの絵が創り出される
創造性を秘めています
時間をかけて 人の手によって作られた
その砂絵は
次の瞬間には崩れ去り
はかなく消え去ります
熊本 —
福島 —
そして 神戸 —
崩れた砂からまた
人の手によって
新たな砂絵を創り出す —
サンドアートは
まるで人生そのもののようです
人のつながりによって形成される
コミュニティそのもののようです
崩れ去っても 力を合わせて
再び立ち上がる —
それこそが 人の持つ
真の力ではないでしょうか？
この日本で Siltを結成して４年
全国を回り
ライブやワークショップを行ってきて
まざまざと感じてきました
砂に触れる手と手 —
重度の身体障害者の子どもの
動かない手が動き —
笑顔になる 瞬間 —
サンドアーティストが描いた砂絵を
「どうして消しちゃうの？」と先生
私たちは 答えました
「いいんですよ 消すのもまた
サンドアートですから」
支える先生たちの 笑顔の連鎖 —
サンドアートの魅力は
つながりそのものにあります
誰しもが 幼少期に体験する砂遊び —
原始的なアート
手と砂だけ
だから心に入ってきます
だから ことばもいらず
すーっとつながれます
最後に Siltという
ことばの意味についてですが
砂よりも更に小さく
砕かれた状態の物質とは
要するに 泥のことなんです
それを知って私はますます
このことばをチーム名にしたいと思いました
泥くさい生き方 —
泥にまみれて働き 生きる —
なんて 人間らしいんだろう？
そう思ったからです
それでは私たち Siltによる
サンドアート『新しい神戸』を
どうぞ ご覧ください
（音楽始まり）
（音楽終わり）
（拍手）